hello everyone
we're just about to embark on a very
exciting week for video games it's not
E3 anymore it's summer game Fest we're
gonna get new announcements Hands-On I'm
getting to see some games I'm very
excited about this weekend some
conferences
um so I thought I would kick us off
by playing some of the Lord of the Rings
Gollum uh which came out while I was
overseas I've not yet had a chance to
play it
um I wanted to do my usual first hour
gameplay get a Vibe for the game I've
not seen any videos or seen any reviews
I just got an inkling that maybe the
game's not very good
um and the way that Gollum looks in this
opening menu is a source of nightmares
um that said
I think I'm very taller than video games
like I like more video games than most
people do uh I I'm just a big fan so
maybe I'll think it's fine maybe I'll
think it's fine I will say great
settings menu
um so let's check it out shall we
don't know what I'm in for uh I am
playing on PC with
um mouse and keyboard and I did see
people play it at Pax uh PAX East in
Boston and I was like wow that looks
really bad
so I did not opt to play it
can't wait to find out
so let me make sure I have the screen
there we go I had it slightly zoomed out
it's a stealth
action
platformer
I love Lord of the Rings I like all them
as a character
okay
without me
no Darkness they see
faces look gobbled no flurry they feel
no breath no cheers that's not to fear
time is not spent loses
I see is this a poem
this is not how Golem traditionally
speaks
[Music]
not roses
uh
okay
okay I'm a bit confused but okay
[Laughter]
to be clear I never want video games to
be bad it's not a thing whether we ever
want
I just
I don't Revel in people's failures I
don't doubt that people worked hard on
this
lost
especially this looks competent
dramatic well-directed cutscene
the darkness grows beyond our borders my
people are growing anxious we cannot let
this evil linger among us oh you
dropping
we believe that he went
you dropping characters we know straight
up
oh want to hear what he has to say
okay
this is very dramatic
[Music]
yep why don't we start with your name
not the one others have given you
Smeagol
I mean
let us try someone else's name
[Music]
oh oh yes you remember him new art style
okay
he found you
more than 60 years ago
deep underneath the roots of the mystery
look this is nice oh
they're trying
from you
okay we've got an idea of the timeline
I'm really not a fan of the acting for
Gollum but this is following the books
not the films
you left your home in the mountains
worming your way down the hills always
hiding from the Moon
you follow the hobbit's Trace All the
Way East to the Lonely Mountain a lot of
exposition but it's okay
it happens
and turn South
why
it's just something that's sick it's
just such an odd choice I feel like
nobody really asked for a Golem game
Whispering your name in your dream
[Music]
okay great yeah
not a terrible opening
what is your name
beagle very well Smeagol
now let us start oh [__] we drop them
straight in immortal
all right I'm hey yo I'm hyped I think
actually everybody's wrong and this
game's gonna be a banger
the shadow Mountains for years Gollum
had dwelled in the mountains of kirith
angol hiding from Orcs wraith or it does
have typos though there's wraith space
and from her dot dot dot the giant
spider he feared and worshiped
um also aux is capitalizing rates isn't
which I would think is wrong I did also
think it was weird that Elven King was
one word
maybe it was a really small team
also a lot of a lot of loading going on
not a loading
hey excitement maybe slightly lessened
by the load okay
unfortunately not great performance
happens
feels like there's two openings here
foreign
to play man I just want to Golem it out
just as I've always wanted
you guys have heard me say that right
I'm just trying to get my Golem on
nice use of color
his face is
not ideal I think it's more that the
textures are really flat that that's
causing the
okay
looks alright from behind
oh well the walk animation is actually
pretty good
it's really hard
um in Game Dev to smoothly I mean it's
expensive oh okay sorry hopefully it
doesn't continue but uh I realized that
this game of all games somehow was
causing my encoding to overload
um
which like never happens to me uh I
don't know if it's like frying my CPU or
something
um but it is uh
not doing a great job of running
so that doesn't seem to be anything to
do about it so this video might just
like break
not the end of the world uh weird use of
yellow there but that's okay
day is near go back to your cave okay
cool the Jump's kind of fun
uh what was it saying oh yeah getting
quadrupeds to move smoothly and like not
have their limbs
fall into themselves is actually pretty
difficult in Game Dev or at least very
expensive or who the top of weeds coming
from fire jump great that feels pretty
good
uh can I wall run no it's gonna be
climbing
this is all pretty standard stuff
and yes drop okay
okay got it
shadow
that is where you are hiding
I don't
I guess I don't have a stamina ball so I
can probably climb forever
uh okay the the choice of putting yellow
where they're putting it is
very disorientating
nice
how much longer is this gonna go for
though because this is a lot of uh
sort of aimless traversal from a player
perspective like why are we doing all
this
nope
it's definitely like the performance is
surely this isn't from my PC
environment's kind of cool
pretty baboons I guess
um we're gonna need to find mirror issue
it's always watching
grab lunch below got it okay
and then the jump box up oh
okay
cutscene time baby
his face
oh gosh
I mean for how much longer do you need
me to climb
the exact same things
is my question
uh seems a little odd
I guess we keep on moving okay
yeah performance Is Not Great oh we do
have a stamina problem okay
I wasn't even close how would my stamina
run out
till day
I mean
the design is clearly tried um but this
does not really look like a game that
came out this year look at drawing
you must have had friends once
it was our birthday yes it was
I also like the choice to have Gandalf
it be here you know that's nice or
whatever
talk to Oxford
no no not anymore
okay
this is just really strange
I hope I don't want to see her
that much
it's also
um
the vibe is
not really that Lord of the Rings thus
far
first person huh
sick bird cool fro
you're gonna make me do more of the same
the same exact climbing
okay got it that thing's kind of cool
I'm really trying
that's kind of that's kind of cool oh my
God what I'm trying to look here
that's a cool environment
yikes the performance uh very
oop my bad sorry
you gotta what why the music
have steaks risen for some reason
okay oh God
um I did Sprint towards the wall
oh okay
new mechanic let's go now we can Sprint
towards walls
boy
I can't believe this game is breaking my
PC worse than
almost anything else I have played
like dude
this is maybe I need to turn the
settings down and Gollum
um let's let's go on on low everything
low and see if that helps shall we
on
off the video off
maybe that'll help let's have a look
again great settings menu
we like the settings menu
I think the game froze though that's
okay
I just also just change a bunch of
settings
it's allowed to freeze
um
hello
bestie
um oh
look but yeah we did it
okay
oh boy
um still pretty rough
I need a coffee
sorry about that okay
can wall run nope still performs real
bad that's
but now we got them here for sixes
oh okay okay
yeah we definitely need to find that but
I don't want the rights to to hear about
what I've been up to you feel me
I mean I understand the objective oh God
why are these so shiny
the glitz why do they glisten so much
and you just cut off its own dialogue
that's unfortunate f is to jump
backwards okay
move over Assassin's Creed
new climbing Sim just hit the the video
game is
okay yeah this is some of the stealth
content it does look rough
okay
that voice acting was pretty solid oh my
God his face
okay
I do feel like they marketed this game
so maybe they they didn't know it was
kind of in rough shape
um
and again I've played worse games
the the performances
is very bad uh
wow I I'm
I don't even know what I'm supposed to
be looking at right now but I'm
surprised that this shipped
with these performance issues
like what's even happening right now
okay
I'm just seeing
oh okay okay I'm still here I didn't
realize okay
weird all right
oh
okay I didn't even know they were there
what do I what do I do do I run past
them
weird [__] look at Orcs I guess I
just run oh oh
no auto fail
okay
uh drop
okay no well now I have him highlighted
that's kind of neat
oh my God the performance ah
this is like painful to play you know
what
I was like it's I'm sure it's gonna be
bad I expected it to be uninspired I'm
not gonna stop playing just yet
but I
this may be the first one of these
videos that I've made where I like play
the first hour of the game and like try
to assess it
where I actually can't get through the
first hour because it's breaking my
brain
um
and it's having a really negative effect
on my recording software and I don't
know what effect that's gonna have on
this video like
okay this is rough dude
it is uncomfortable to play
uh
how do I get past them
just drop down
here maybe
oh God
um
I don't know
was I am I able to climb around them
okay I can just run
oh my God
wow those Orcs
look like weird brutes
good drop cool
that's how fun are you ever went into
Mordor
oh
I did that because
yes
because it didn't let me
um move any lower try that again oh my
God is have I have I done something do I
need to reload the game is this on me
what is going on
tried to change some settings see if I
could make it run any smoother
um I can't
and again I haven't looked at like other
people's videos or reviews or anything
so I don't know
if this is just the game's performance
um but it is
probably the worst performance of any
game I've ever played
um
and I've played a lot of games uh I
don't know like I feel like there's
something I'm missing like that I've
misconfigured something in some way
because
it's just so bad and I've seen like tiny
little gameplay chunks where people's
games didn't look like mine does
um for reference I'm running a 3080
but nothing else I've played this week
performs like this like I don't I don't
know if this is on me
not trying to misrepresent anything you
know but like it this game
just does not want to function on my PC
which um is a bummer so so excited to
play it
like I keep missing dramatic moments
because
the frame rate drops even during
cutscenes
I would like to see ring rights so that
sounds cool
environment's kind of pretty
his eyes she's always
it's very weird to play as a character
that like you can't relate to at all in
this kind of way as well
like again anytime anything dramatic
happens in a cutscene I can't see it
huh
don't need it please don't eat it let it
just let it go don't eat I don't need to
see that
spy
[Music]
okay
you will know but it's two of them but
quiet stay in the shadows mustn't lose
them you mustn't lose them okay
I'm telling you it was a little one
stay closer than precious
I do think having like the alter ego
help with tutorialization is smart
stay stay in the shadows literally where
bestie
oh gosh
ain't nobody
what am I supposed to do about him
what
oh I gotta climb here
I wasn't sure about that uh all right
[Music]
what was that sound effect what is going
on
uh I feel like I'm losing my mind
okay I had to jump up and then up again
that's it okay
whoa why did you do that oh my God okay
stay close to them precious
doesn't he call the
sorry about that oh look what happened
to my eyes why why has that happened
okay
so I go uh I'm an up up at the top
I mean Bailey we'll be fine
don't get too close precious
we put these little candles up here
literally which orc did that
open up
all right let's have a good one
yeah okay
that's a weird interaction all right I'm
just confused like this game is
certainly melting my brain
um
because of the performance
if this is the gameplay Loop for the
whole game as well obviously pretty
lacking
um but really it's the performance
problems
oh that sounds fun
that could be fun we could have a good
time doing that
getting people ate by a giant spider
it's a shame I'm terrified of how to to
be honest
and who put all these here
this guy's kind of nice okay
yeah I I just can't see very well Gollum
I I'm getting a new pc
at the end of this month and I'm like do
I wanna
oh
I can attack someone
oh I didn't expect that
oh my God it takes a long time
okay
okay and then is he just gonna stand
there because it's
really
authors why can't I just attack him
he's just standing there
okay if you say so
aim
pictures
what the [__] is going on dude
a bit of an overreaction
because I hit a lantern with a rock
what
oh I got rid of the light well that
shouldn't have made him full but I
understand okay I apologize Colin the
logic sort of makes sense
I didn't realize she was right here and
why are they in here
I also just expected like more spider
webs movie I don't know
yeah oh man
the artist did a good job
oh
just gonna eat it for sure yeah
or not okay
find us
The Beatles
what if it's friendly what the [__]
wait so wait wait wait wait wait oh I
got to choose between government that's
kind of cool
but is this whole game just me thinking
that animals are spying on me I guess
that's interesting
Smiggle keep watching Gollum kill Beetle
and hide keep watching
now convinced Gollum
um
what the [__] is this
yes it hasn't been following us has it
it likes us look
what the [__] okay that's kind of a cute
idea I really like that particular art
and I'm glad I got to not kill the
beetle hey Choice based video games
um
that could be kind of cool
spoilers it's a ring Wraith
okay
I feel like this is maybe a little bit
too long for what it is
hell yeah dude
I feel like this should be like maybe
some more sound effects here
we've got music but
that's it that wasn't gameplay you could
have made that a cool set piece that
probably got cut the scoping the
cutscenes are
usually pretty expensive
that could have been cool
really I'm sure that was cool in the
script
show with the team Reddit they thought
it would oh why is my health gone
what hurts how did I get injured
I didn't do [__] the game's just
deciding I'm injured
[Music]
I mean now it sounds cool but they're
not there anymore it's a shame
[Music]
okay pick mushroom great eat food is
hold X
well done my dear
okay the beetle did not do that you were
just in the open
one more
okay
gollum's intuition and heightened senses
oh what's this
for what that's what what for
he's just trying to somebody go this way
maybe that's strange
is this like a visual representation of
intuition
okay
I wonder if this is like an auto fails
Chase sequence kind of thing
performance is better in here at least
oh
oh I don't know
dead end
gotta be to the left
[Music]
okay
this is
um I mean
like cool in theory but oh he's that
that's cool
oh there's two of them what
the [__] am I supposed to go
what do you want from me I don't
understand
I mean it really made it look like you
wanted me to go this way
but isn't the ring wraith right there
so then [__] what
I don't understand
what in the UI
I mean do y'all just want to take me at
this point like what the [__] am I
maybe he'll just walk past and then I go
to the left
no okay well you just you could just
have me let's retry that not that I know
what the [__] I did
they are cool though
ick
very dramatic okay
[Music]
okay
I'm just really confused
about
like most of it
I wonder if it performs better on
Console
um
I prefer not to buy the game twice but
maybe maybe I'll get a better experience
on PlayStation 5 you know
maybe it's a PC issue
as we keep having as of late
it's not a Golem issue okay make games
run on PCS is hard
nobody blamed Gollum
I'm not I'm still really sure what those
things what direction they were telling
me to go in
because they just kind of stopped after
a while
oh was I supposed to get I got an
achievement was I supposed to stop there
what is happening
oh
well what the [__] was Golem's intuition
good for
look at me
they brought you to him didn't they
the dark lord
what did you tell him
what did you tell Sauron
okay I was supposed to get caught that
was really weird autofill or a scripted
failure
nice
so he knows
an interesting place to put the timeline
like the storytelling
you know you've you've done it
I feel like it has to have just been
like massive budget restrictions is the
problem
like a small team and just a really
small budget is my best guess
or too much money spent on cutscenes
okay
after being questioned by the dog load
himself Gollum was thrown into the slave
pits underneath the Dark Tower
gotcha level two let's go
so long
and again this game is just making my PC
[__] itself
I really didn't expect that to be an
issue
of all things I expected
Golem being the next Crisis was not one
of them
come on buddy
I think the art is still nice
things I think they did well are
the 2D art is very pretty
and it seems like environment art
um
like the concept artists had some vision
the uh and I think
the means to tell this of Storytelling
is interesting conceptually
maybe not so much an execution that
wraith bit was very bad
okay
it's also just a weird thing to put
someone through like who wants to play a
game where you just get treated like
[__]
forever you know
did he throw that
okay I guess he did
chapter 2 the maggot great
can I take it can I talk to the oh my
God oh my God
I want to talk to this dude
frail man
be quiet you won't get us all killed
Roger that okay
I'm gonna grab this slave tag [__]
out
well you can't [__] you're a slave too
oh I'm going to sleep when the hole is
clearly big enough for me to escape
why
this is so [__] weird
day one
what was the point of that
why
okay
oh [__] hell dude okay
oh my God the performance ah this is
like honestly painful to play I don't
even know if I can
if I could do it for much longer
okay
oh my God where do you want me to go
this way
oh this is like a cool little orc
elevator
that's sick dude
okay
my brain is melting
um
it's like I'm afraid of it
like I'm confused and startled and
unsettled
in a way I don't know any other game is
has ever
made me feel this way
and I I can't look at things smoothly
and the camera snaps in into weird
directions without me wanting it to all
the time
and the loading screens are so long
and there are so many cutscenes that
that just aren't needed
um
and really long loading screens
and for what
it's a it's an experience man okay
Maybe
maybe what they're doing here is
actually very meta
which is they're trying to make you feel
like a suffering in the real world so
you have the same emotions that Gollum
has
um
in which case game of the year
it's nice nice and colorful what is that
thing not a dwarf not a goblin too ugly
for either of them harsh
yes
but what why is it frozen what's going
on okay uh oh God okay
[Music]
I swear I must have like
there must be something about my PC
setup that is making this game just
break like this can't be
what everyone's experiencing you know
how like sometimes you just have like
the a weird combination of things that
QA couldn't have comprehended like it
could even be like how many USB ports
you have actively got things plugged
into I swear this can't be
the actual performance of this game
there is no way it's this bad
also if there's anything that people
love it's um
the running faster than NPCs who walk I
guess I can just outrun them that's cool
okay later fools
foreign
like he's just had a lot of
opportunities to escape so far I would
think
but okay
look at your name
uh
you're going to die down here in this
vagina cave nice
okay the beasts if they run at you find
cover get to High Ground if you can they
don't have the best eyes open the pens
and lure them in there then quickly
close the gates okay all right
I will help you
okay interesting new objective ladies
and gentlemen
the gate is not for us
first things first the slaves chase the
captain okay
okay I gotta run away from some stuff
to break the levers
that's why there is another one on top
now down on the other side carefully so
I have to just lure it into the cave and
then jump up to the Lima
I assume
up column up
great okay let me just go here
and pull the lever
and that's it beautiful okay got it I'm
a genius
seems simple enough what a weird
thing
these ones are bulls so I wouldn't trust
defenses to stop them
this is so strange should I get into
Higher Ground I want to know what these
design meetings look like like somebody
they have to come up with a series of
many games that will like maybe oh [__]
I didn't realize they were already
chasing me that would maybe constrained
to like
the fact that
all you could really do is run from
stuff
I should have been around stamina
has promised
find the pressures for him he swears
okay
oh [__] that's just the [__] game's
performance did that
that wasn't my fault
oh okay yes
sometimes it just like pulls the [__]
camera away from me oh my God uh
dude I can't see
oh
[__]
for some reason this does not use
stamina yep
okay try not to do that again
something dude yeah we got it
I think we have to go this way
oh
across this
she's not Young great okay
shouting precious Beastmaster will tell
us
not too bad okay for your first day not
too good either I mean I did my job
today what
this is so weird
what a weird
choice
like
I'm just confused
like how how I want to talk to people
who worked on this real bad I know this
isn't like
anyone's fault it has to just be like a
limited resources thing
it just doesn't make sense you make me
run away from two of the same thing
put them in cages why
am I doing this like
there are ways that you could make I
think making a Golem game at all
most people probably wouldn't want to
but um
there are ways you could make this
interesting and that the pitchfa okay so
that he's a slave and then we make him
put some beasts into cages and then we
go to the mines
how you know
how did this come to be
it just doesn't make sense
all right report to the mine orc
[Music]
s don't listen to her there's a reason
she's in a cage
I don't think I could do this for any
longer
the performance is just killing me man
who doesn't know doesn't know the words
does he
and what does a good slave
the [__] is that he learns maybe you
should run little slave
why slave simulator
what the [__] dude
I can't do it anymore I can't do it
anymore I can't handle the performance
um the game itself
excuse me I could at least
probably tolerate and continue to like
analyze
the performance is making me want to
throw up
I'm out I tried there's a fire song I've
ever done this I've not made an hour and
I've been like you know what
I cannot do this anymore
I'm sorry Gollum
my guy we've really tried we tried